how should someone think about building
a framework of how they can take the
tactics that we talk about today and
actually use them as we mentioned at the
very start compliance adherence you can
have the best strategy in the world if
you don't end up applying it it means
nothing what is your best advice on how
people can form a framework of tools
that they can actually use
I think you have to start with the
objective uh so so everything I talk
about I've always talked about this way
or at least you know for more than a
decade and I certainly have written the
book through this lens which is you go
from objective to strategy to tactics so
we always want to start with the
objective and I do think it's worth
being clear for any individual what
their objective is and I take a lot of
time with patients going through this so
um you know when you go to your doctor
that's not a common question what is
your objective and again it's not the
fault of the doctor I think it's the
fault of the system the system isn't
really set up to ask that question the
setup the system is more set up to kind
of play a bit of whack-a-mole is there a
problem right now is there a symptom
right now that I need to address
but if you're trying to play this sort
of long game you have to work backwards
and say okay
what do you want to be true at the end
of your life and the the framework that
I use for that is called the marginal
decade so the marginal decade is the
last decade of your life everyone will
have a marginal decade and that's not a
pleasant thought for many of us to think
about right I don't love thinking about
the fact that I'm going to have a
marginal decade but I will now you never
know the day you enter your marginal
decade
um but many people know when they are in
it
and the question then becomes what do
You Want To Be True in that decade
so let's play the game with you how old
are you Chris 35 okay so let's assume
that you know
fate will smile on you and you know God
forbid you're not going to have some
premature death you know you're not
going to die in a car accident next week
or be stricken with cancer in you know
10 years or something like that so let's
just assume your marginal decade is kind
of the ninth to Tenth decade of your
life
what do You Want To Be True in that
decade
I would like to still be able to move
without assistance what kind of moving
uh I would love to be able to still walk
okay uh I would love to be I'm adore
dogs so being able to take the dog for a
walk being able to throw the ball
golden retriever okay is that a big dog
yeah big for a 90 year old yeah okay
that's okay okay this is you can be
ambitious here I am ambitious yeah big
golden retriever okay
um
we're gonna be able to walk a golden
retriever yep how far
30 minutes a day okay yep uh maybe twice
a day if I could at best Hills or no
Hills
uh not so fussed about hills okay Hills
can Hills can go but do you want to live
in a house that's got uh a balcony okay
so would need to be able to go up and
down stairs okay
um would love to still be able to pick
up grandchildren I have no idea whether
that's realistic at 90 years old but
that would be something I'd love to do
pick them up from the floor from a crib
okay
um
would love to have still a good quality
of sleep
um
and
would love to be able to
have sex at 90. yep not something I've
considered good question let's say yes
let's say yes I'm still going at 90.
okay
um
and probably most importantly above all
of this is still have proper cognitive
function like still I I value the
quality of my thoughts more than
anything on the planet
um I still want to be able to learn I
still want to be able to satisfy my
curiosity you know if I was still able
to have conversations like this at 90
that would be just fantastic to me
uh I assume you don't want to be in pain
that would be good okay
so again we could drill into this a lot
further but I think what would emerge
and by the way this is a this is a
valuable exercise because I don't think
a lot of people do this
um but I I think everybody needs to do
this and needs to go really far down the
rabbit hole and what you'll realize is
um by the way everything you've said is
totally reasonable like I have some
people when you play this game with them
you know the first thing they say is I
want to be heli skiing when I'm 90 and
it's like I'm not going to tell you
that's not possible but like that that's
the first thing you would say is a
little odd right but everything you're
saying is is achievable but is
challenging
so for example walking a golden
retriever
um at the age of 35 you don't even have
to think about it
but if you actually look at the force
that's in that leash and the amount of
balance and strength and lower leg
variability you need to not fall over
when that's happening
by the time you're in your 70s that's
going to be very difficult so you have
to build up an enormous Reserve in those
capacities today to cope with and
anticipate the inevitable decline that's
going to come in all of those so
so that's that's how you start you start
with the objective you reverse engineer
what the implication of each objective
is and you you know you you we
understand pretty well what the decline
of those properties looks like I need to
stop you that how realistic is it for
some male in his 90s to still be able to
have sex without any assistance well it
depends how you define assistance I
think the use of like phosphodus Trace
Inhibitors is probably going to be
required what's that like a drug like
Viagra or Seattle understood
um but otherwise I think it is realistic
um but again like think about what that
comes down to so a big part of that is
going to come down to your microvascular
system
so there's a reason that you know having
type 2 diabetes having atherosclerosis
is an enormous cause of impotence
it's it's not affecting your brain what
it's affecting is microvasculature the
blood flow of the penis so there's a
there's an argument for being very
metabolically healthy I mean I see this
even in patients who are in their 50s
and 60s who at one point are completely
dependent on drugs like Cialis and then
you get the metabolically healthy and
all of a sudden they're like oh I don't
need this anymore I wonder how many men
who aren't that concerned about getting
overweight who aren't that concerned
about losing a foot but if you tell them
that penis would stop working that would
be the final motivation for them to look
after the diet whatever it takes Okay so
we've got uh objective yeah then we have
to think about what the strategy is
right and this is where I think
um
it's very complicated in this problem is
this where people get lost I think so I
think this is the step that most people
just skip all together and go right to
the tactics so they say okay I hear you
on objectives now tell me how to eat how
to exercise how to sleep Etc
um and I think you can't skip this
bucket and there's a reason that those
like chapters in the book that are
devoted to this
um
if you're playing
um if you're if you're trying to if
you're asking questions that are
straightforward you don't really need a
strategy so if you said to me
Peter my objective right now is not to
get a sunburn
we don't need a major strategy like it's
relatively straight we can go straight
to tactics you're going to avoid the sun
altogether if you need to be in the sun
you're going to wear long sleeves and a
hat and you're going to wear sunscreen
and blah blah blah and it's it's pretty
straightforward but when you say my
objective is to live 10 years longer
than I otherwise would and do so at a
much higher function as evidenced by
that list of things you just said
well I can't just jump to tactics
they're not obvious so instead I have to
go through a whole bunch of indirect
measures because I don't have what I
really want right what I really want is
I'd love to be able to rely on the gold
standard which is randomized controlled
experiments that would give me the
answer
but for reasons that are self-evident
and obvious and not worth explaining we
don't have randomized controlled
experiments that answer all the
questions that pertain to taking a 35
year old and setting him up to be the
best 95 year old
so we have to have an option b and
option b really rests on a whole bunch
of other pillars of strategic Insight so
one of those things is what are the
inferences we can make from
observational data of long-lived
well-functioned humans so looking at the
centenarians for example who we very
quickly figure out are genetically
gifted so they're they're they're their
superpower was picking the right parents
but we can still learn a lot from them
uh we'll put that aside for a moment the
other thing we can look at is short-term
human studies that don't cover the heart
outcome such as the full duration of
your life but cover certain things so
for example there might be hard outcome
studies that look at heart disease or
stroke or heart outcomes that look at
performance and functional metrics such
as strength resilience and things like
that we then look at animal literature
or non-human literature I think to be
more accurate that looks at the full
duration outcome so I think we can look
at some of those animal studies and get
a pretty good sense of what's affecting
lifespan and health span but we have to
be careful with it like we do with
everything and that we we want to be
very thoughtful that we're not just sort
of zeroing in on one model so this is
again where where we look at things that
favor lots of models so you know
something that's consistent across mice
and worms and flies and dogs is much
more interesting than something that is
only going to work in one Mouse model in
one person's lab
then we want to look at mechanistic
studies so how can we understand for
example the benefits of exercise when we
look at the cellular level when we
understand them you know when we look at
proteomic metabolomic changes of
exercise and how do you know what do
those things tell us as an example about
say exercise or sleep restriction or
dietary restriction and then the final
tool that I think we look at in our
strategy bucket is mendelian
randomization so sometimes
you actually let nature do the
randomized controlled experiment for you
so mendelian randomizations are very
elegant types of studies where when you
can find genes that are responsible for
phenotypes of interest you can ask the
question as nature shuffles those genes
do we establish causality by the outcome
so when you put all five of those
together that's how you start to Cobble
together what your tactics are and
that's the final piece of it so what are
your tactics you basically have five
domains you have all things that pertain
to what you eat all things that pertain
to how you exercise and move how you
sleep all the drugs molecules
supplements hormones that you could
possibly take and then all the you know
call it the bucket of things that you
would do to manage emotional and mental
health
when you break it down like that
longevity seems very simple that you
have these five key areas that you're
focused on
where are people focusing their
attention in your opinion when it comes
to both Health span and lifespan
longevity
that have the shortest levers but people
are giving undue attention to
yeah that's such a great question I I
think what's what I find funny is that
everybody and I'm sure I mean I'm not
sure I know I've been guilty of this
myself it's
it's very tempting to just focus on your
favorite thing like there was a point in
time where virtually all of my attention
was focused on nutrition
like I really felt that nutrition was
the the Alpha and the Omega of this
entire equation and all you had to do
was sort of eat a certain way and
everything was going to work itself out
um
obviously the medical establishment is
hyper focused on the the medicine side
of this as evidence by the fact that's
the only thing we learned in medical
school and residency right it's not like
anybody taught you how to administer
exercise or nutrition even if you knew
that those things mattered you had no
education in how to actually do anything
about it it would sort of be like an
oncologist who knows chemotherapy is
good
but doesn't know anything else like
doesn't know which chemotherapy or what
dose or what schedule or what biomarkers
to use to track the progress of the
chemotherapy in the um you know in the
tumor as it regresses so
um
so each each entity I think just kind of
has their own expertise every single
morning for over three years now I've
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue regulates your appetite it
optimizes brain health and it helps curb
Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relying on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
grief and policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you'll love it elements are
giving away a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box if you
go to the link in the description box
below or drink
lmnt.com
MW that's drink lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]